Today's new members of the day are George
Newhall and Jake Thibeault.
Thank you to both of you for supporting the
program.
Also, a big thank you to Alan Kasell.
Allen, is today's long-Time sustaining member
of the day.
Membership is our primary funding source.
Money doesn't grow on trees.
We've many, many of us have been told.
And it also doesn't just appear in our bank
account for the show.
We do depend on the support of folks who go
to join Pacman dot.com and grab a membership.
Very cheap, very quick, very easy.
And you will get the daily bonus show, which
people love.
I'm reading everywhere that people just absolutely
love it.
Okay, guys, I have news for you that may surprise
you.
We may not have a second wave of corona virus,
but the reason why is not so good.
It's because the first wave may actually never
end.
We are already now halfway into June and it
doesn't seem like the first wave is going
to end, at least at the national level, because
of a number of new exploding, exploding hotspots.
The out of control case growth is happening
overwhelmingly in Trump states states with
Republican governors.
So first, let's get this out of the way, because
I know people are going to want me to talk
about California now.
California is the exception here.
California is a state with a Democratic governor.
They have been on paper lockdown for a very
long time.
But things are not going well in California.
I have no interest in hiding this from you.
California has been so-called closed for months,
but their cases are going higher and higher,
not precipitously, but they are going up.
It's not clear what's going on.
My brother lives in L.A. says seems a lot
of people are just ignoring the guidelines
that he drove by some restaurants that were
open with people sitting inside without masks.
So it seems as though what's happening in
California, at least Southern California,
is people are just ignoring the guidelines
that are in place.
But most of the early contagion's states that
were early hot spots have curves that are
looking really, really good.
An example of that is New York State dramatically
turning their curve around here in Massachusetts.
I'm just genuinely thrilled to see that our
curve has fallen off a cliff.
There is a spike last week.
If you're looking at the chart, it's a it's
a false spike because on that day they added
presumptive cases from the prior three months.
So that's a bit of a it looks weird, but we've
only got around 200 new cases per day here.
There are only a couple hundred people total.
I'm talking about in the entire state left
in ICU use, outdoor dining is safely reopening.
I sat outside at a cafe this weekend.
I put a picture of me doing it on Instagram.
You'll see just how safe it is.
But in the meantime, while things are improving
dramatically in many states, a ton of right
wing states that reopened early or never fully
closed are failing hard.
And it is difficult to watch.
In Florida spiking so aggressively that the
chart I'm showing, it almost looks wrong.
But that is the real data to the extent that
it is not being understated by Florida, which
has been a problem in Florida, then in Texas,
again, cases climbing more and more and more
with worse and worse looking numbers.
We look at Arizona, where I have a bunch of
friends.
Arizona.
It's climbing in Arizona as if we're at the
beginning.
Their friends told me almost nobody's wearing
masks indoors in stores.
Everything's open.
People are pretending everything's fine.
And indeed, the case numbers in Arizona reflect
that.
There are others we could look at.
North Carolina is a big one.
We're also cases just will not stop climbing.
So let's talk about something now, because
I want to I want to deal with the disinformation
propaganda that's going around ahead of time
so that you will be prepared to fight it when
you see it.
There's a narrative that we're hearing from
the right that the problem with corona virus
in the United States is Democrats in power
because the early hot spots are all liberal
cities and Democrats are terrible at running
cities.
And it's chaos.
And that's why we have if it weren't for Democratic
led cities, this never would've been a problem
in the United States.
Now, most of you know that that's ridiculous.
But they will then go on to say, because of
those early failures by Democratic governors
and mayors, the virus has now spread to red
states, even though red states did all of
the right things and blue states that all
of the wrong things.
They're also now starting to blame Mexico
for some of the spikes in places like Texas
and Arizona.
There is no evidence of that.
So this is a completely disjointed sort of
sort of Gish Gallop narrative that they are
putting together.
And I want to give you a coherent, sort of
unified theory for what's going on here.
The early hot spots were caused by two things.
Population density and many direct flights
to the areas.
Most affected where the early cases were coming
from.
Right.
The early hot spots in the United States were
New York, San Francisco, California, Chicago,
Boston, as examples.
These are four of the densest.
These those are actually V4 densest metro
areas in the country.
Not necessarily highest population, but highest
population density.
And they have tons of flights to Asia and
Europe.
Here in Boston, we had nonstop flights to
multiple Chinese cities.
Tons of flights to even more Chinese cities
via Hong Kong and Tokyo and other places.
We had nonstop flights to Italy, other European
cities where we now know Corona virus already
was there in late twenty, nineteen and early
2020.
Same thing.
Illinois was an early hotspot.
Chicago O'Hare Airport.
Major hub for American Airlines flights.
United Airlines.
I'm going from memory here.
San Francisco.
Tons of flights to China and other Asian countries
with one stop.
You can get to even more cities in China.
New York has multiple major airports.
New York has LaGuardia, Newark and JFK, Newark
and JFK, both individually or some of the
major gateways to Europe and to Asia.
And you had two of them there.
So that's why early on the cases started in
those places.
And right wing states often said then we don't
have to do that much because we're not having
a problem.
These blue states to different degrees locked
down and started mitigation and cases slowly
trickled throughout the country into red states.
But a lot of the red states never fully closed
or did but reopen quickly or did.
But people ignored the guidelines.
And over time, the early hotspots that were
brutally hit because of the population density
and the flights to the hot, the the early
areas in Europe and Asia were mitigated.
But the red states, meanwhile, were just churning,
as is a popular new phrase on the Internet,
churning cases.
And when you look at the timing.
Yeah.
The blue cities where the early hotspots.
But you look at the curve, it was up and then
down because of what was done.
Look at some of the red states in March.
They really weren't having a problem in April.
They were only having a small problem.
But when you look at the curves now, they
haven't even peaked.
These curves are horrifying.
It's just up, up, up.
And in 10 days, it could be absolutely insane.
And some of these places, I'm genuinely glad
right now to be in Massachusetts where everybody's
wearing masks at indoor businesses are positive.
Test rate is down.
Yesterday, it was like one point five percent
of all the tests done yesterday.
Ninety eight point five percent of the people
tested did not have the virus.
That's a very, very good sign.
What's going on in these other states is absolutely
horrifying.
Now, just one more thing to protect you from
disinformation.
The right wingers are or are also insisting
cases are up in red states because there's
so much testing going on in those places.
This is not true.
The data's available.
Take Florida as an example.
Florida recently had a 36 percent increase
in new cases, but only an 18 percent increase
in testing.
The positive test rate went up to seven point
five percent on that day in Florida.
If you test more people and find a higher
percentage of positives, that's not good.
And they will also say, well, cases may be
up, but hospitalizations and deaths aren't.
Those are on a 10 to 20 day delay.
So the cases that are increasing now will
be followed by deaths and hospitalizations
tragically over the next 10 to 20 days.
Don't fall for the bogus talking points.
Understand what's going on and recognize we
may not have as sick a discretely identifiable
second wave because the first wave may never
end